après marine c'est light veulent pas du
tout les monty maurette j'admire yens
meriem ben oui c'est bien que je viens
de faire varier la rade
non non mais parce que c'était ma grand
mère c'était comme ça wells et meriem et
maire de maman elle est très très jeune
et comme le montre c'est un beau prénom
le plus merrienne ça veut dire marie
dont myriam trouvé voilà c'est ça et on
va forcer un peu comme ça pour la radio
qui patrick meyer il est relié non je
pense pas que c'était ça je pense que
j'étais pour la radio il pensait que
clémentine ça faisait plus plus
accrocheurs je sais très bien que s'ils
n'ont pas la chance et comme 6-3 en un
peu plus d'un coup il ya un coup c'est
pas de me voir je vais sens oui non mais
ça change quand tu as dis ça donne un
côté plus gai comme ça plus c'est
différent quoi et ça m'a au début ça m'a
fait du mal et puis après je me suis
c'est pas grave parce que vont
finalement et il faut j'en fais ce que
j'ai envie je suis comme on l'a dit
cette jeune et clémentine main geci pas
et alors tu étais obligé de coucher avec
des avec des gens pour arriver oui un
non mais parce que toute façon et des
filles plus belle que moi ouais et puis
j'ai pas envie de coucher pour savoir si
je n'a pas été obligée non
donc ça mais ça tu crois oui je pense
que c'est vraiment invitée à petit il va
buter le plus avec des producteurs
non je pense que c'est vraiment moi j'ai
jamais été obligés et et en plus je
l'aurais pas fait il avait fallu parce
que enfin ma vie tu veux c'est comment
dire c'est moi je crois j'ai très naïve
et je vois les choses qui sont de pures
permattant on l'a vu dans bon t'as vu
dans les nanas ottavino doute chine mais
enfin dans 37 de oui et dans la gitane
quand même des rôles assez
pourquoi on donne toujours des rôles de
l'info tamila sache c'est pour ça
croyable
pas du tout ces deux fois par leurs
proches non mais non mais je sais bien
non mais c'est deux fois ça et dans 37 2
c si tu veux par exemple tu vois c'est
cette femme c'est pas une nymphomane
entre ces deux alors mon amour qui a
besoin d'amour qui en fait que tu suis
ambitieux je serais vraiment quoi est
donc simplement le seul truc c'est que
j'ai trop difficiles dans ma vie en
général c'est pas sexuel et c'est un
tueur ben je sais pas ce qui fait que
quand on me donne une occasion comme ça
d'exprimer les choses
j'ai envie d'exprimer fort de façon
excessive
et comme si petit dans 37 2 forcément
les gens comme je saute sur quelqu'un
ils me disent ah oui là m'a foutu voix
mais bon c'est vrai quand tu étais petit
j'ai trouvé que deux lettres aux gros
seins mais très vite oui parce que la
poitrine lâcher les écrase un peu mais
non non je n'écrase pas désempli tout
mais la poitrine c'est il faut
s'interdire mais de façon intelligente
quoi il faut s'en servir comme une
harmonie dans le corps en général dans
sa vie en général moi j'ai le corps que
j'ai pas de ma faute
les noms mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que comment dire je ne peut pas
dissocier sable voie de la paix sic j'ai
c'est vrai et c'est quand on a trop
d'appétit au cinéma c'est pas forcément
bien il faut être très patient
il faut être tu vois il faut être
tempérée au cinéma je mange et boit
mathilda may du ca qui est une super
fille qui a reçu le césar
elle a quelque chose de tempérer
convaincante elle dit merci tout ça est
là quelque chose comme catherine violent
tous ses grands dieux dans l'est et moi
j'ai pas ça alors forcément bon là dans
la musique j'ai une rencontre forte
j'ai envie de faire rejoindre et cinéma
dans cette rencontre forte que j'ai mais
bon il faudra un certain temps tu vois
mais voilà tu tournait un film qui
s'appelait de sable et 200 et jeanne
labrune est à découvert s'est découvert
le sud
oui a changé ma vie
voilà c'est un être calmes ans qui était
quelqu'un de très pur vainquer qui était
comme un an je suis un ange qui vient
d'une planète où et quand j'ai entendu
ça plusieurs fois j'ai eu un choc très
grand et j'ai eu envie même si
j'appartenais pas de sens et de ma race
et de demain
de ma culture dans l'univers du tango
flamenco comme ça du jour là il faisait
que j'ai la chance de rencontrer antonio
et toutes ces personnes qui sont avec
moi qui m'ont accueilli qui n'ont pas
afin qu'ils m'ont accueilli qui n'ont
pas rejeté et qui m'ont permis de de le
faire mais je sais c'est sûr c'est pas
prétentieux je cherche dessus personne
j'essaye de j'ai une rencontre
simplement de choses d'un univers tu
vois le flamenco pense c'était tout un
univers une façon de vivre que de que
juste une musique et ça me permettait
d'en bas 2 millions ont été les premiers
à passer camaron à la télé en france
alors les avait menés 10 à qui son ado
je vais faire maintenant tu veux mener
deux carrières parallèlement voit le
cinéma j'ai pas de carrier ça va te
faire j'ai pas de carrière ce que je
fais c'est ma vie ouais et il se trouve
que là tout d'un coup je rencontre des
personnes qui me permette de vivre et
d'exprimer ce que j'ai envie de vivre
parce que eux dans ce qu'ils vivent eux
si tu veux il me dit
ils me disent vous dit tu peux le faire
par exemple dans c'est vrai que bon j'ai
dans ma vie j'ai des ménages souvent que
j'ai du mal à m me méfie ce nouvel
endroit est vrai que j'aime les couleurs
c'est vrai que j'aime quand on peut
s'exprimer quand on peut faire les
choses avec le coeur et que là tout d'un
coup le flamenco ça me permet de de
l'iss a complètement